you've got quite a history haven't you
working with joss whedon what's it like
compared working on something like much
ado compared to Avengers and also of
course angel well different but the same
I mean Joss of course is always
extraordinary always intelligent always
sensitive I love working with him and
Amy that combination of Jaws Amy and I
that's a very special special
combination so if there ever if there
were involved and I'm asked I just say
yes and of course Fred and boise get it
happy ending with mono I know at last
yes all that suffering is is uh is
finally put to rest here in this film
yeah I mean we're not strictly speaking
Fred and Wesley in this particular story
but for those fans of angel then there
will be a little bit of a sweet a sweet
extra now we see you running up and down
the stairs and it's while you're doing a
modern approach I don't know that's a
lot of work I mean you know I took the
approach this is a real guy this is a
soldier you know I know he's very
verbose but I wanted to kind of keep him
keep him as somebody we all have had a
drink with you know and so yeah we I
knew the whole monologue and just who
had told me to learn my lines i took him
at his word and of course i do tend to
learn it's helpful if you learn your
lines when it particularly when it
Shakespeare but we came to that day and
he said he said oh my god you you really
did learn it all and he said well we
should shoot it as one and so we did
it's very easy I have to say it either I
you know it would stumble on a word or
the or the camera operator had to fill
me and him going backwards down the
stairs yeah it was it that was a tough
morning now next movie after much ado
we'd like to see many more Shakespeare
by you enjoy what would you like to do
next ideally well I I don't know that I
whether I would be part of it but I
think Josh would interpret Hamlet
extraordinarily well yeah he we read it
at his house we've read it a couple of
times different people in the role but I
think when he read it was one of the
most electric electric versions I'd seen
so let's get him to play it yeah I'm
liking your idea to be his great coming
out on screen
you